forget about 24 hours when you finally
came back down to earth update us on
where you are i haven't come back down
to earth like i'm still like what the
[ __ ] is like what is going on
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
good evening everyone
good evening good evening uh first of
all
uh to kick it off i just want to thank
people for being here it's great to see
him i'm excited about all of you seeing
this
i but most of all i just want to thank
everybody who showed up
uh there's a hundred trillion things
that are going on uh during this week
and you could be everywhere or anywhere
and
you're outside it's a little chilly i
appreciate the perseverance and we're
really excited about having you here so
there's some seats open if people want
to sit
um and i just i'm really grateful that
you're here thank you for supporting
this so yeah let's pop that up
so i
you know
i think i put out a lot of content and
talk and all that so i'm going to focus
on getting stuff out of people for all
of us because he's harder to get stuff
out of so mike
what's up
let's start with
have you spent the money yet
it's gone that money is gone
[Laughter]
tell us like no like honestly i think we
can all get like the normal stuff this
is a small community still this is
what's fun about when things emerge
on a serious note when something that
remarkable happens and we'll see a lot
of footage here
i think it's been well documented the
moment i i do think it's the watershed
moment for the space
punks you know board ape there's been a
lot of things but i really do think your
sale
is
the one that most hit people's radar the
extremity of the sail probably caused a
lot of reaction and we that's all well
documented i actually want to dig into
the human that you are
what happened in in the first forget
about 24 hours when you finally came
back down to earth
like where update us on where you are i
haven't come back down to earth like i'm
still like what the [ __ ] is like what is
going on like i'm still like
it feels like it's still very much like
something that i have not processed i
processed it more than you know 24 hours
later but
it's still something that i think
a lot of people are still trying to
grapple with like what is going on right
now um just because
the world was a certain way and then
over the course of just a few months the
world was a different way and not just
to me what what to a lot of people
what's different for you
as an artist
a lot of times that level of commercial
success can really change it
how are you do you feel like you've been
affected
look at it differently is there like how
are you as an artist like what's going
on
um i would be lying if i wasn't say you
know i'm not affected by this at all of
course i am i'm a [ __ ] human and i
sold a [ __ ] thing for 70 million
dollars like
[Applause]
[Music]
it literally feels like silly even like
saying it um
so yeah of course i'm affected but
that's where i feel very lucky to have
been in this sort of framework with the
everydays where i have to keep doing
work so
the sale happened at 11 a.m
i have to do a picture each day by
midnight so i had 13 hours before the
next piece of artwork i was putting out
there was no like
oh [ __ ] now everybody's watching me blah
blah blah like it was like man
everybody's it is what it is i got to
[ __ ] do this thing in 13 hours um and
so
that really has allowed me to just kind
of sort of keep plowing forward and i
know that
most of the artwork that i'm putting out
i'm not gonna sell or at least i'm not
gonna immediately sell maybe um and so i
think that sort of takes a lot of the
pressure off that it's not like are
people gonna like this is it gonna sell
like blah blah blah it's just like it
was just like it was where it's just
sort of like i just do it people [ __ ]
with it great if they don't whatever
it's not
i think i think that's amazing i
actually think that's how you got there
in the first place what
what is your observation
of the market right now you know i think
one thing that is very underrated about
you
so many people view you as the artist
you had this big sale i
got to know you it's why drock and nima
and the team got to go to your house to
make this
when that auction was going on in that
first six you know that six or seven or
eight weeks that we got to know each
other before this i viewed you
as somebody that understood the market
that there was a lot more of what i'm
good at in you
than a lot of artists that come along
which i think is what led to a lot of
that success so when i ask you this
question i'm just genuinely interested
because i think you're gonna have an
interesting observation what is the
current state of the nft art market from
your perspective
i think what is probably different from
me than a lot of other maybe artists or
people in the space is i think i have
more of a healthy dose of skepticism
than most people and so i'm always
trying to
like this is too good to be true because
it feels very much too good to be true
i'm always waiting for it to be like
jpegs just kidding they're not worth
anything what were you thinking
like
and because for a long time they weren't
worth anything and so all sudden it was
just like
wait now people are paying for this [ __ ]
it's like wait what the [ __ ] like does
when you make that statement is there a
part of you
that
knows that it's not like just kidding
the whole thing goes away forever but
yeah but is there a part of you
that does believe
that it's a gold rush and it's similar
to things we've seen in the past where
right now it's so fever pitch there'll
need to be a correction and they'll come
back later on
i would say there are certain projects
that i would be surprised if they stand
the test of time uh like what
[Laughter]
not be friends
[Laughter]
um
the um i i think it's one of those
things where
nobody [ __ ] knows i i'm not going to
sit here pretend like i [ __ ] know and
anybody who's telling you what they they
the space is gonna look like in five ten
years they don't [ __ ] know uh and
that's what makes it interesting and
that's what makes it exciting um
but i think you know as long as you're
sort of investing in creators and teams
that
you know you believe are going to
sort of
be around for the long term because i
think
it's very easy to make promises and it's
[ __ ] free to make promises oh i'm
gonna do this and i'm gonna blah blah
blah and it's like yeah but are you
because at the end of the day
if you don't then the thing is not going
to be worth [ __ ] yeah and so it's it's
funny my favorite thing that emerged in
the last six months is the road map
like everyone's like the road map like
you mean the pitch deck from every
startup that failed in the last 15 years
like this obsession that the road map
was this very important thing i think
it's just fun to watch this space make
the same exact mistakes that web 2 did
where it's like no you don't get it gary
it has tokenomics i'm like every project
will no you don't get it gary gaming's
going to be big no [ __ ] dick face right
like like you know i think people get
confused what a dick face what a dick
face
mike tell us back to more fun before we
go into the film what was the most
ridiculous phone call you got within the
first week after this monumental moment
there was a bunch dude well give it to
us we want to be entertained people are
freezing their asses off give them
talking to [ __ ] madonna it was just
like well let's talk about that now i
well that's guy will kill me guy or kill
me
you talk to madonna
i did did it go well yeah yeah well okay
what else
garyvee called me
[Applause]
what about like some third grade friend
who was like yo
there was definitely some people who
came out of the woodwork where i was
like oh yeah i remember you that's it's
been a sec it's been a sec um
but yeah i think it just it obviously
everybody has been super positive and
super supportive and so you know
i have a big question that i think a lot
of artists here
and projects here
you know because i think just to remind
everybody if you're here
like this chamber gets real small real
fast
just to remind everybody like 99
of the world has no idea what the [ __ ]
going on here right now
and so this is super early which means a
lot of good things are going to happen
to a lot of people here as long as you
don't get caught up in the biggest
vulnerability in this space which is
people love to say things like it's
about the art and about the community
let there be no confusion 90 of the
behavior in our space right now is about
short-term money and it is the
vulnerability yes everybody complaining
about things
if you look very carefully it means it
[ __ ] up with their short-term bag so
we have to be thoughtful but
i do believe a lot of people here will
have versions yours is pretty extreme
but i'm pretty confident that there's a
lot of faces i'm looking at now and
we'll look back at drock's footage and
be like oh [ __ ] they were there now
they're doing this that's what happens
when you're early in the thing that's
going to happen
do so this question is loaded in that
do you
feel pressure
now because people have invested
extraordinary levels of money into your
art do you feel that you have to
execute for the next
year's
decades to justify those costs and does
that weigh on you or do you feel like
the market is the market like how does
that sit with people
uh it doesn't really there is pressure
but it doesn't
it's not hard for me because at the end
of the day i was doing this for free for
20 years i was getting up and trying
really [ __ ] hard to make digital art
the best i could for 20 years before
anybody gave a [ __ ] before
before anybody would pay for it and
that's where it feels too good to be
true because it's sort of like i'd
already seen again i was pretty popular
before this in terms of you know the
digital art community and this or that
and so i'd already seen a bunch of
benefits from from doing that and so
that's where it was like
wait so now people are gonna pay a lot
more money for it um
and so
i think at the end of the day all i can
do is get up and try really [ __ ] hard
and that's it and like that's what i was
doing before and that's what i'm doing
now and so i'm and i know i'm trying way
harder now too and so
that's it like that's all anybody can do
well listen uh there's
probably a lot of places a lot of people
are trying to get to so i think we got a
little bit here i really i'm so grateful
you're here i'm incredibly grateful to
ryan harwood and the 137 pm team yes i
want to yeah definitely thank the 137 pm
team because you guys crushed it with
this like super happy without and thank
you for like making this happen like
very very much the best part was drock
nema j the team was there and they were
texting me and they're like
he likes us and he doesn't like all the
other people that are here and we're
like super fired up and uh i'm really
really glad that everybody's about to
see this i think the work is really
strong selfishly
what i think ryan and i want to do is
put out more long-form tyler we want to
put out more long-form meaningful
content and so this was a real get for
us we knew we were recording something
and uh we're really proud of it and
thank you so much for allocating your
most precious asset of time to be here
with all of us and i think it's time to
play it so
are you guys ready thank you
thank you for being here thank you guys
thank you seriously
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times uh i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my commitment and
exploration of youtube is about to
explode stories polls more content more
engagement more surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you